so rising inflation rising interest
rates rising fuel prices and
many other prices going up as well
plenty then to put to our panel of
experts let me introduce them to you
this evening we've got anna stevenson a
senior welfare benefits specialist we
hope to be joined very soon by vicky
price the uh chief economic adviser to
the center of economics and business
research and uh also there baroness
altman ross altman uh former pensions
minister personal finance expert and
conservative peer very good to see you
all too will soon become three but let's
crack on with the questions and our
first one comes from paul this is the
question that paul is putting how does
increasing interest rates how does this
happen today of course help with
alleviating the cost of living crisis
when fuel and food increases are out of
control
kick us off anna i mean how is that
meant to work it doesn't really help
anyone who's got any kind of borrowings
um i'm guessing this is one that was
supposed to go to one of the other
guests but i'll i'll have a go but this
isn't quite my area of expertise my
understanding is that the idea is that
it should
uh take some of the heat out of the
market and slow down inflation um but i
i do hope that someone better informed
than me will be able to come in on this
soon now you spot on and succinct but
but
ross altman just expand on that for us i
mean it does seem we we know what the
bank of england's got to do it's got to
try and get inflation down but this
actually doesn't help anyone with uh
dealing with the cost of living crisis
no and that's a very difficult balancing
act that policymakers are currently
faced with you know a lot of the
inflation is is caused not by
domestic factors but by uh outside
forces so to the extent that you know
the war in ukraine and higher
uh prices due to global supply chain
problems
are occurring changing interest rates
isn't going to make much difference to
that but there is also at the same time
uh a little bit of what the bank thinks
might be overheating in in the domestic
economy unemployment is at a record low
uh there are plenty of jobs and in fact
job vacancies all over the place
and
a tiny increase in interest rates that
we've seen today
is really more of a signal
um
to try and dampen expectations that
growth is going to be really
strong and try and control
the overheating that's been going on in
the housing market maybe stop people
borrowing quite so much encourage them
to repay their debts rather than take
out new debts because interest rates
have been exceptionally low for an
incredibly long time it's interesting
what you say there about it's a signal
rather than an attempt to cause any uh
real economic pain to consumers uh david
i just want to stay with you on that ros
about
inflation and uh david's got a question
which i suppose is about how much of
it's domestically generated and as you
touched on there how much of it is due
to well external factors really beyond
the uk's control uh he asked with the
main causes being global issues
how will an increase in the uk interest
rate make any difference and that is the
point we we know the answer to that a
little bit but so many factors aren't
controllable within these shores
yeah and and of course that there is
also the uh impact that we haven't
properly seen yet of falling
uh the falling pound the weaker the
pound is the more imported goods will
will cost in in domestic sterling terms
so the bank of england needs to raise
interest rates as a signal to the
markets
that it is willing to try to control
inflation but if inflation is uh due to
temporary factors you know the unwinding
of the bottlenecks
due to the pandemic and hopefully
the war in ukraine will not continue and
there will be less pressure
on
energy prices and input prices
that itself might help to dampen down
price pressures an interest rate
increase in any case
tends not to have an immediate effect on
the economy the bank is typically
looking you know
a year ahead at least
and giving this this signal that
the era of
ultra low interest rates is probably
pretty much coming to an end
the bank clearly doesn't want interest
rates to rise sharply because that could
tip lots of people into real
problems with the extremely high levels
of debt we've seen
um and therefore there is this delicate
balancing act a lot of the recent
inflation
is due to the uh after effects of the
pandemic
and
the recent
ukraine
war situation
and just in terms of that signaling is
the bank of england taking a radically
different approach or got different data
or are there different circumstances in
the uk compared to the united states
where we saw the day before the federal
reserve go for a 0.75
increase and it's only 0.25 percent here
well
the big difference in in the us i think
is that the
fiscal policy itself the government's
um
overall policy stance over there has
been
extraordinarily
accommodative you've just had
as a result of the pandemic
just a few months ago
everybody was sent a huge check from the
government to try to maintain spending
now that has boosted the economy
while in the uk
you've actually had the chancellor who's
just uh increased some taxes especially
national insurance for example so
although we've had a cut in
fuel duty and and some relief for energy
bills
overall
there has actually been a bit of a
tightening of fiscal policy in the in
the latest round and and the government
has so far signaled
that although it wants to cut taxes in
the longer term and medium term maybe
2020 just for
it could be that before that there will
be
some more tax rises in the pipeline like
an increase in corporate taxes which
again
uh offset some of the need for a much
sharper increase in interest rates well
that's a big picture stuff let's go down
to some people's personal circumstances
uh
this one from jay says people on minimum
wages are not getting any help how are
we expected to survive
work doesn't pay
anna do you go along with jay's point
i mean we have seen a long time when
real wages have fallen and at the moment
they really really aren't keeping up
with inflation so i can absolutely see
why he's feeling anxious
um there is some support available for
people working on minimum wage the first
thing i should say
is that um a lot of people assume that
they can't get benefits if they're
working and that's just wrong around
half of people on universal credit are
in work and there's been some changes
recently that have increased the
generosity of universal credit for
working people so if you haven't done a
check in the past few months to see if
you can get universal credit and you're
feeling the squeeze it is really really
worth checking it's free it's
confidential it takes about 10 minutes
you can go to the turn towards website
and it is very very simple to check
um there's some other things that people
on minimum wage will be seeing so from
july the
threshold for when you start paying
national insurance contributions goes up
and mostly it's going to be people sort
of earning
um
over 9000 pounds a year but not earning
very large amounts who really benefit
from that um so you'll probably see a
little bit more in his take-home packet
from july
um there's also going to be the 400
pound payment which will go out to
almost all households in the uk um that
will help on energy bills through this
winter so there is some help coming um
but at the same time i really can see
how people are finding that their wages
just aren't
keeping up with the rate at which all
prices are increasing
well jasmine has a related question to
that i'll stay with you and she's more
or less asking perhaps as i would have
done for you to expand
on this people who are on low incomes in
work claiming their benefits so the
specific question is this will those on
a low income that just missed the mark
for qualifying for benefits receive
support income is still very low and
many are left with barely enough to
survive at the end of the month and that
is the point down there isn't it there's
a there's a cut-off point and so you may
only be a few pounds a month over the
limit for benefits but life is still
really tough at the moment
absolutely yeah um you know this group
of people probably did get 150 pound
council tax rebate but that may be a
distant memory by now
um
as fuel costs increase so fast i can
really really see how people are
struggling um like i said there will be
this
400 pound on energy bills through the
winter
and there will be um the changes to
national insurance that come in in july
so there's going to be a little bit of
extra help but it probably is going to
be a pretty hard winter for a lot of
people and the government is
fairly plainly saying we can't help
everyone and we do expect this to be a
hard time for a lot of people well they
specifically said that today we heard
that from michael gove and just on that
just just i mean you mentioned that
point about benefits do you think some
people may think they're not eligible
but as the government itself admits a
lot of benefits go unclaimed it's it's
worth checking everything isn't it
it absolutely is a lot of benefits go
unclaimed people very often assume that
they can't get benefits without actually
checking and like i say it's so quick
it's so easy to check um turn towards
website turn2us.org uk plug your details
into our benefit calculator and just see
if there is help you could be getting
you might well be surprised yeah you
never know um a mix then between uh the
relationship between uh personal income
and the overall economy from declan uh
asks smoke taking money out of people's
pockets when they're already struggling
mean less money enters the economy which
will lower gdp and then create a
recession i suppose sparing assault when
you call that an unvirtuous circle
well this is this is the dilemma that
that we're currently in if you want to
curb inflation the typical remedy for
that
is to stop uh growth
uh that would normally lead to a major
slowdown
but usually you have high inflation when
growth is
is going gangbusters and of course at
the moment growth isn't and that's where
you know there is this fine line between
trying to
send a signal to the markets not to
expect
inflation to last the bank
bank of england keeps saying actually
you know we don't expect this to be
permanent we expect this to be
you know maybe dying down by the by next
year
and we need to ride ride over that
because if we jack up interest rates in
the way that we normally would for
inflation of 10 or so which is at least
is expected
then the the economy would tip over into
recession we'd get people losing their
jobs companies going bust
which is exactly what the low interest
rate policy was meant to avoid in the
first place
so
you do you do need to to
look at whether or not
this is permanent and of course
if
we we see a position where
the war subsides the global supply chain
issues subside
energy prices start to come down again
then at least you'll see some unwinding
of this and we'll get back to be able to
judge what really is happening
underneath
rather than with all the exceptional
factors that have been going on but the
government is is trying to help those
who are generally considered to be
most vulnerable those on the
means-tested benefits lowest income the
650 pound cost of living payment first
of which will come in july and then the
second one later this year uh we'll just
be passing legislation to
make those payments uh at the moment so
if you're on a universal credit or
whatever i'm just plugging in here
because we're nearly out of time for
this section uh both of you and the next
couple of questions cover some of the
points you've been making there baroness
hotline now hannah asked why are the
government doing nothing to support the
current crisis and anthony asked could
we see a further increase in inflation
if i can put those backwards just stay
with you
ross altman on that issue of um well you
know it might pass you know that's the
point it might we heard what i remember
in october joe biden saying the rising
inflation was transitory boris johnson
more or less echoed that here we are
nine months later and you know the
picture further out
is still looking fairly bad the the
answer is you know why can't
policymakers and politicians be honest
they actually just don't know
well that's certainly true um
but nobody would have predicted the the
pandemic and nobody would have predicted
the war in ukraine everybody said that
russia wouldn't invade and suddenly here
we are dealing with the consequences to
some degree
um
so you know it is that there is more
than a normal degree of uncertainty
there's always uncertainty
uh
the way statistics works you know
typically if prices have shot up very
fast this year then the comparison next
year with this year
even if prices stay roughly the same
will be a very sharp uh reduction in in
the rate of inflation that's reported
but what we what we don't know and what
is well what is unlikely i think is that
there will be
a massive boost to growth
coming again you know what we've seen
lots of people getting money from
governments both in the states as i said
and
over here now so there'll be support
but it is a really tough time and and i
feel for those who are just above the
means testing network who are really
struggling with the cost of living and
pensioners elderly people who really
just
encourage you to even pay them yeah
getting their pensions eroded by
inflation and just that question from
hannah anna why are the government doing
nothing to support the current crisis
would you give them that that they're
not actually doing nothing they just
can't do enough
i mean it is an enormous crisis and at
turn to us we have pushed really hard to
see government support and we're really
actually quite glad to see the way
they've targeted the very most
vulnerable people who have no space in
their budget to drop other things apart
from fuel and food so
the government is doing things they are
doing
quite a lot of different things but the
fact is that the scale of the crisis is
enormous
and the government has chosen to focus
that intervention only on the people who
are the very most vulnerable
okay listen i'm glad to say um thank you
both very much indeed for holding the
forward on some of the uh economist
questions because we're joined by uh our
economist there she is in the middle now
vicky bryce good to see you chief
economist uh chief economic advisor to
the center for economic and business
research uh vicky got a question for you
from andy uh during the last big
recession interest rates were dropped to
stimulate the economy with another
recession looming what takes precedence
and this is the chicken and egg question
raising or lowering interest rates
rocking a hard place
absolutely and that's exactly what the
central banks have also found right now
they felt they had to raise interest
rates and in some cases like in the u.s
very substantially and it's happening
here too although not quite as fast as
in the us because of the very high
inflation that we are experiencing right
now
it is a big issue because
uh clearly
this is an external problem that we've
all had to face and i'm sure you
discussed that as well so energy prices
food prices going up very little to do
with what
the economies in the west have been up
to very little to do with the expansion
in money supply and the very low
interest rates we saw uh during the
covet crisis but it's a lot to do of
course with the war in ukraine supply
chain issues that we met
immediately the moment that we opened up
because basically everything had been
dislocated there had been so many
cancellations of orders from
manufacturers so uh people were not able
to then respond very quickly certainly
if you look across the world you had
problems with china responding
semiconductors
not really available for cars etc etc
in addition of course we've had the war
in ukraine which had made things
considerably worse now
unfortunately for the central banks they
are not really quite uh capable of of
doing this proper balancing act right
now of caring about inflation but also
about growth so if you were looking at
where we are in terms of the serious
slowdown in the economy you would think
the opposite you would think that
interest rate should really be coming
down rather than going up
and at the same time of course what
we've got is a monetary tightening and a
fiscal tightening uh because a lot of
this support that was given to the
economy has been removed in the uk in
particular we've been putting taxes up
so right now the balance between
monetary policy and fiscal policy isn't
right
so my answer would be that if we were
able to relax fiscal policy right now
you could still perhaps raise interest
rates up to a point they're still very
negative in real terms so for everybody
who's worried about being able to meet
their mortgage payments of course
they're going up in nominal terms but in
real terms if inflation is up at eight
nine ten percent and interest rates are
at just one point two five percent where
we're talking about a very
negative real interest rate environment
which therefore shouldn't by itself it's
gonna be down and pretty low by
historical standards as you've been
saying so richard asks this one and so
many other people wondering as well uh
we saw interest rates raised to double
figures in the late 1970s and more
recently than that of course some in the
1990s as well to combat high inflation
what is the likelihood of that happening
this time round that we get into
really high interest rates 15 20
i would say it's very unlikely one of
the reasons why interest rates were
raised a lot in the uk at that period
was also huge concerns about the
exchange rate of course and also at
various stages uh attempts made to keep
the exchange rate high when we were
trying to
uh sort of attempting any way and
thinking about possibly joining a
currency union with the rest of europe
now we didn't do that we
decided to abandon that idea
and lowered interest rates based
significantly the pound of course fell
so we had periods uh like that in the
past the forecast now for interest rates
uh
is that you might get two three percent
in the us maybe three and a half percent
we might get a doubling from where we
are here in the uk but certainly nothing
like what we've seen before not in
double figures and the expectation is
that those inflationary pressures we've
got it now are going to go away
over the next year really and by the end
of 20-23 we may be
almost back close to target if prices
don't continue to rise anything like as
fast as they've done so far so if they
plateau if if for example oil prices
don't uh rise much further than where
they are now then you see a very
substantial drop in inflation happening
very quickly in that environment
double digit interest rates are just not
just uh justified at all okay well
that's the the outlook thank you very
much dee for taking us through that
vicki bryce i want to put this one to
you anna from marianne and we touched on
this but just expand um we only hear
about how hard it is for people who are
working what about pensioners who can't
borrow or get loans and of course i'll
add in they're on on a fixed income
which has been eroded by inflation
yeah um pensioners are going to be hit
really hard by
rising energy bills
uh that is partly to do with the fact
that their incomes are fixed and it's
harder for them to work it's also to do
with the fact that it can be harder for
them to just um choose to do without
heating that that can pose a much higher
health risk for older people
um
the first thing i'd really like to say
is that um pension credit which is the
benefit for older people is desperately
under claimed um
very large numbers of people could be
getting pension credit and aren't the
government has been doing a bit of work
this week actually to try to increase
take-up rates and if your pension age
yourself if you know someone who's
pension age it is really really
worthwhile checking if you can get that
pension credit not only does it increase
your income it also gives you access to
a whole load of extra help that you can
get once you're in receipt of pension
credit and identified as one of these
low-income pensioners who needs extra
support
so that extra help includes things like
650 pounds that's extra 650 pounds
people on the lowest incomes pension
credit is one of the qualifying benefits
for that
um
engineers will also be getting an extra
300 pounds on top of their normal winter
fuel payment they'll also get the same
400 pounds off their energy bills that
everyone gets so there is
they're getting support they're getting
extra support and they're getting extra
targeted support um to try to help
people and in addition to that the
government has committed that in april
it will um increase benefit increase
pension age benefits in line with
inflation so that's that's a hugely
expensive commitment government has made
so
this is a sort of lag while pensions
state pensions
fail to keep up with inflation
that's practical and useful advice there
anna check your pension credits we're
going to end uh this section before we
take a short break um with a question i
suppose that um goes from the personal
and illustrates a much larger problem
leo says i'm a 15 year old student from
liverpool who has a mother suffering
from the cost of living crisis how is it
beneficial to tax her instead of
companies who could pay more than
quadruple the minor taxes they currently
pay i mean ross altman we know that um
corporation taxes due to go up there's
been a windfall tax on some of the
energy companies but um it does seem
unfair doesn't it that people
individuals have been taxed more highly
than some of the multinational
corporations operating in the uk
yeah and i think there was a particular
problem and i wish the chancellor hadn't
done it
a lot of us were trying to persuade him
not to that
the national insurance rate was
increased
uh just in in the last few weeks which
cuts her take-home pay but his mom will
then benefit from the increase in
thresholds that is coming in july so
you've had a fall in take-home pay right
now which is a terrible time for that to
happen the chancellor's sort of
recognized that and is going to be uh
improving the situation from july it's a
shame that we had to give with one hand
uh take with one hand but we're giving
back with the other and and
it is uh absolutely i think right to
suggest that big companies particularly
those that have done very well out of
the
pandemic itself and perhaps out of the
increase in energy prices
should be taxed more highly whether
that's a windfall tax or just some other
way of raising the revenue the same with
some of the online businesses that have
done very well
those are areas which i hope the
government is looking at to increase
some of the taxation burden on them
rather than on ordinary people
okay listen it's been really good
talking to you all and we've got much
more to come from you in the second half
we're going to take a a short break now
where you rest those grey cells because
i've got plenty more questions coming up
to tax
excuse the pun you are with from our
audience you are watching sky news a
special question and answer program
coming up after the break we're going to
be asking uh what support is there for
those who work but are still struggling
stay with us
[Music]
welcome back uh we're answering as you
probably know your questions about the
cost of living crisis with our expert
panel let me reintroduce you to them
we've got anna stevenson a senior
welfare benefits specialist vicky price
is the chief economic advisor with the
center for economics and business
research and baroness ross altman former
pensions minister personal finance
expert and conservative peer and so as i
say the questions have been flooding in
all day to us
illustrating i suppose the scale
of this crisis jane asks this what about
the people who work full-time who are
unable to claim any financial help and
are still struggling they can't just
help those on benefits workers are
becoming the forgotten people of this
country baroness altman you know we
we've kind of touched on this when it
comes to benefits but um people in work
who are above
the benefits threshold there is the
issue which you were just mentioning um
tax cuts when in actual fact for those
apart from the very lowest paid taxes
are going up
well that's right there's this temporary
period where
national insurance has just gone up
which is very unhelpful uh but it's
about uh to go down again in in july so
uh the national but not for everyone
no um for those who are in work and the
thresholds have have come
have been increased significantly so
unless you're on a very much higher
income you know those who are just above
the means testing level will benefit
from this
um and the national living wage has
increased by
6.6 which of course is behind inflation
but it's still a significant
increase of about a thousand pounds a
year if you're working full-time
and and there is at least 400 pounds for
every household with their energy bills
so
it's it's a problem because the
government hasn't got an unlimited magic
money tree either and i know
that people are struggling uh the the
best way for this to calm down is for
the global
pressures on raw material costs to start
coming down but i do hope the government
will do more
to recognize that you know people in
work also need help
people just above the minimum thresholds
could end up a lot worse off because
they're not getting the extra benefits
that means testing entitles you to as
well okay another question about that
about someone in work this is matt i
don't know if he's got a family as well
but he says he earns a reasonable above
average salary of 36 000 pounds i'm
struggling to cope with the cost of
living what help is there for someone in
my bracket i'm currently using credit
cards to get by but it isn't sustainable
that is for sure matt um any help with
that anna it's not very wise
to use credit cards with a huge rates of
interest but if you've got no
alternative that's where you're going to
end up
yeah i'm definitely pleased to see that
he recognizes that that's unsustainable
and i would encourage him to get advice
on how he can manage his money more
effectively as soon as possible the
money helper website has a really great
um tool that can help you to find free
confidential responsible debt advice so
that's where i'd suggest he starts um
because yeah it really isn't going to be
sustainable to find his day-to-day
living on credit cards
um
again if he hasn't checked he really
should check if he can get benefits um
especially with the changes that were
brought in in autumn winter last year
the amount of help that's available to
working families is really quite
surprisingly high um so if he if he
hasn't done a check in a while it's a
very good idea to check he could be
getting any benefits
well we've got a lot of questions as we
would expect about um
driving their cost of fuel i'm going to
roll a couple together jim says what are
the government doing about the rising
cost of fuel and dave adds to that
saying the government's tax take has
increased hugely through rising fuel
costs while they're reducing fuel tax to
bring prices back down and i want to put
this to you vicki price because clearly
the exchequer take has increased because
of the rising cost of fuel does it have
enough in its coffers to at least cut
vat or fuel duty as well on fuel
it does i mean of course you're just
going to have to borrow a little bit
more
but they borrowed so much the government
has borrowed so much during covert and
that didn't uh
provide any huge difficulties for
being able to go out to the markets and
do so so
there is room
still
but the interesting thing about fuel tax
more generally
is that the the general concern that
people have about reducing fuel duty is
that we're going completely against
anything that we have been talking about
on climate change until now and it will
be very very difficult then to
put it back up again
uh we hadn't in fact raised fuel duty as
we should have done for a good sort of
12 years um and if we had done so in
line with the previous increases we
would have probably ended up with hugely
more headroom for the government now to
be able to redistribute it so for the
moment it isn't huge but of course yes
extra vit
has been helping now the real question
is about the future
people are already driving less
so less will be collected in the future
we're seeing the slowdown in the economy
we're seeing what's going on with retail
sales and so on some of the what the
government was supposed to be collecting
in the future may just not be there
um and there's also talk of course of
reversing the national insurance
contribution increase that uh it has
just been mentioned
uh
which if it were to happen takes away an
awful lot more again uh from the
government coffers so we have to be
careful and and it's worth just just
adding that
what the international monetary fund for
example the international institution
which is looking after the sort of the
world economy making sure that money is
transferred to the needy countries that
are right now of course increasing a
number he's saying we shouldn't actually
subsidize
fuel
um our energy what we should really be
doing is just redirecting fiscal policy
towards those that need it most so
benefit increases for example
giving these allocations that the
government is now doing to everyone not
just
uh perhaps to those who are the bottom
end but more generally because it's
hitting loads and loads of people in the
middle
income distribution as well so so it is
a difficult situation for for anyone but
there is no doubt that if the government
was intent on redistributing more even
by reducing fuel duty even further then
there is room for maneuvers but what
about
vicki bryce i mean that's the government
uh pete highlights this with uh our next
question about four courts always quick
to pass on increased fuel costs don't we
know it but painfully slow
to reflect decreases will we ever see a
liter of diesel return to less than one
pound 40 and the and this is the fact i
know president biden in the united
states has written to all the the
so-called big oil leaders saying well
look you're making these huge these
massive profits you're very slow to
bring down the cost of fuel when the
wholesale price drops is this something
that can be sorted out that these big
corporations can be can be forced to
pass on the cuts more quickly
well as we know there's been uh
well if you like hasn't been a study yet
but it's been a commissioning of a
review by the competition authorities in
the uk
of what's happening in the four courts
and and are we perhaps being charged too
much and are they indeed keeping the
profits rather than passing some of even
the fuel cut that was supposed to happen
the fuel duty cup cut that was supposed
to happen onto consumers uh there there
is some evidence that not everyone's
been doing it uh there is some evidence
that quite a lot of focus have in fact
been passing at all but it is absolutely
true that when prices go up
then uh we see petrol prices go up very
significantly as well uh you know the
pumps and when they come down it takes a
little bit longer for this to happen so
there's no doubting therefore that
something happens with the margins of
those companies and indeed there is a
question mark as to whether
one should look again taxing them a
little bit more than we do at present
even though obviously they're still
taxed quite significantly given the
current system as it exists the
president all right um you mentioned
vicki price there you know the fact that
people are already we're seeing people
being unable to drive and of course it's
economically and socially absolutely
necessary for so many people and this
question from paul illustrates that uh
rose altman pretty soon people won't be
able to drive to work what is the
government's plan to tackle this and i
was reading i mean there's so many
examples of this i was reading just the
other day hearing about
you know a social worker many of whom
pay home visits they're so so important
you know because of cuts and pressures
even before this they've only got 15
minutes or so with the people they're
going to visit
now
when they fill up their cars they're
putting over a hundred pounds worth in a
day to to get round it's unsustainable
isn't it the government has to do
something
well it is unsustainable and somebody
needs to help
at some point if this continues because
uh social care workers for example will
will be unable to afford to work and
they will stop working and we'll have an
essential service that doesn't have uh
people to fulfill it with already
shortages but that might mean that the
employers of those people will have to
start covering the costs of travel
and
i think one of the government's plans is
to improve public transport to encourage
people to use more
um trains and bus services
and also to well that won't work next
week to share cars or to move to
electric vehicles
because that again cuts the cost of
running the cost of owning and running
an electric vehicle is now far more
attractive
than it was before all of this happened
but yeah i mean just on that uh band
assault when you mention that i mean on
on electric cars they've just cut the
grants to buy them that's
the wrong direction excuse the pawn of
travel
well it depends because the advantages
of of the electric car are now
much clearer they help the planet they
are also much cheaper to run
and that's where the government thinks
to itself well actually we shouldn't now
um be subsidizing these it's rishi
vehicles
yeah stop talking about all of this
we're doing a wonderful job the
government no seriously though no it is
really hard
yeah you're right i mean but you know in
terms of practical help you're saying
public transport electric cars well as
i'm saying well you know public
transport there's a huge strike taking
place next week you know not entirely
the
government's position to do too much
about it but it could certainly twist
some arms some more couldn't it
it's certainly trying and and it's
actually very disappointing that uh the
opposition hasn't condemned these
strikes you know next week i think for
the rmt union to come out as it has
interrupted the young children's exams
and people getting to work you know this
is you know with this current fuel cost
crisis we need to be able to rely on
public transport more okay um more
questions coming up another breather for
you uh you're watching sky news tonight
coming up more questions including when
will the cost of living crisis end and
also how long is a piece of string
[Music]
welcome back we're answering your
questions about the cost of living
crisis with our esteemed panel of
experts lined up behind me there as you
can see uh let's start then with our
next question from philip interest rates
on savings are not rising in line with
borrowing rates why is that vicky price
that's about banks and their margins
isn't it
it is i'm afraid and that's been
happening all along so if you look at
any period in the past when we've had
interest rates go up what you find is
that what banks are prepared to pay
uh lags hugely behind what the bank rate
is and when they start going down
it's the opposite i'm afraid it's a
little bit like the vegetable prices we
were discussing before
because in reality when interest rates
are quite low you know banks don't make
enough margins so just therefore profits
tend to suffer so they try and make it
uh when they start going up and that's
basically what tends to happen so the
margin widens in terms of the difference
between
uh what your your the base rate of the
central bank is the one that set that
short term rates and what you get on
your savings so i'm afraid we're
probably going to have to suffer from
that for a while but they have been
creeping up their savings rates um but
i'm afraid they're still
ridiculously low so i talked earlier
about how interest rates are negative in
real terms well if you look at savings
rates well they're mega negative
our hearts bleed for those banks and
their tiny margins we'll have a whip
round for them shall we um
another one relating to to banks and uh
and their ability to lend i suppose from
justin so many people wondering this
it's all about getting your timing right
is now a good time to buy a property or
will the housing market collapse some
crystal ball time baroness altman
yeah
it's
tough making that call isn't it right
now
well it's it's very tough but also you
have to you have to say that house
prices have have rocketed
the cost of buying a home has become
extraordinarily expensive relative to
average salaries
and perhaps the housing market is due a
bit of a breather and a pause and
usually
if interest rates are starting to rise
then
you wouldn't expect the housing market
to continue
to soar ahead but that might help some
of the
younger people getting onto the housing
matter
and of course as
interest rates
stay far lower than inflation
if people have got big
debts elsewhere
then the real value of their debts
erodes so
you know there are swings and
roundabouts to some of this and some
people
won't mind if house prices cool a little
bit you don't want to crash or a sharp
fall but it might help people start to
get more onto the housing ladder
but then you've still got the
affordability issue because the cost of
their mortgages will still be rising
uh question from students we haven't um
mentioned a sizable section of the
population yet so here let's rectify
that kate asks what help is there for
students they don't qualify for benefits
but are facing higher prices of course
they are this will only push poorer
people out of education and further
inequality inequality if i can say it
anna what help is there for students if
any
kate's quite right that students really
have been missed out of a lot of these
support packages
the maintenance loan increase is way
below inflation
so they are going to feel their finances
much much tighter over the coming year
most most students don't qualify for
benefits though there are some
exceptions
um
and
it is going to be quite hard um some
charities do offer grants to people who
are studying and are struggling for
money uh tendrils website offers a free
search facility where you can look for
charities that help people like you
your university might well have a
hardship scheme and depending on exactly
how your rent's set up it is possible
that some students might get that 400
pounds off their energy bills but quite
a lot of students if they're renting
from say a big student housing provider
or if they have a rent deal with the
bills rolled into the rent amount might
well not actually see that 400 pounds so
they are they are really being missed
out at the moment okay last question uh
i'm afraid from leo which is
yeah well do we have a prediction of
when the cost of living crisis will be
sold and if so when um vicky price is
about a minute each you want to ask ross
for her view on that
when
well i think
oh yeah
you start vicki i think you got there
slightly earlier
oh oh right so it was a competition
sorry about this uh i didn't mean to do
that uh but uh it's a it's an incredibly
good question and the most difficult one
of them all and i think the government
knew uh that then they would act in a
certain way to make sure that it's it
finished quite quickly i'm afraid uh
it's going to be with us for some time
because the war in ukraine seems to be
continuing so it's going to be a
prolonged conflict i'm afraid and and
the food crisis that we've got right now
is likely to get worse um before it gets
better because if you can't
import the fertilizers that you need for
example it's not just the shortages of
presence but also whether you're able to
plant things for the following year or
whether it's at all you know
economically viable for you to use the
very expensive fertilizers to ensure
that you got you know enough for the
next season so if we find that people
don't the farmers don't in fact plant or
get the
the plots ready for next year then the
food crisis might continue for a lot
longer than we would have imagined
baroness altman uh did you go along with
that i mean certainly a tough 2022 ahead
yes yes i mean a lot of the
big price rises due to the war in
ukraine particularly
relevant to food probably haven't fully
come through yet and there's more to
come on energy bills for households but
i would be very surprised
if this lasts more than
one or maximum two years
the government will have to cool things
down but you don't want uh this to be
cooled down by a crash in the economy
you want it to be cooled down by
an unwinding of the factors
the global factors you know the pandemic
after effects and ukraine war that have
actually driven much of this
and let's hope that the bank of
england's judgment that
interest rates
don't need to rise enormously
to conquer inflation and that it will
subside within let's say the next 24
months which i would expect it proves
right
finally balanced as
has our panel been thank you all very
very much indeed baroness altman vicky
price anna stevenson uh answered as much
as you can in this hour of television on
economics all the way from the macro to
the micro thank you once again and see
you again soon very hopefully